hi my name is Leah Lewis and I play
ember in Pixar's Elemental and I'm mama
dawace and I play Wade and we are here
to play buzzfeeds which element are you
quiz
[Music]
so mama do first things first how would
your bfff describe you kind Brave
sensitive reliable spontaneous
optimistic I wonder how Theo would
describe me I think Alexia would
describe me she's right there
my best friend is sitting there would
you say I'm sensitive or Brave
yeah that's I'm I'm struggling between
those two as well kind no he knows I get
irritated
my best friend you know what I'm gonna
go with brave I'm gonna go with brave
too yeah I'm gonna ask him later so Mama
dude you just moved to a new city what's
the first thing on your to-do list check
out the nearest rooftop restaurant
nearest rooftop restaurant
um take a walking tour of the city hit
the beach join a class to meet some
locals and uh uh check up with my milk
check out The Nightlife nope uh visit a
museum dude I would do all of this in
one day interesting I'd probably go eat
I would take a walking tour immediately
of the city I could see you eating
sustenance is everything eating first
for sure choose a popular Disney song to
sing a karaoke oh my goodness You've Got
a Friend in Me by Toy Story you're
welcome by Moana Un Poco Loco from Coco
I love that one we don't talk about
Bruno and Kanto Let It Go Frozen I sing
that for my high school graduation it
was so embarrassing it had nothing to do
with it
no Hakuna Matata tell me that story in
full I want to know all right you just
had someone sing at the end of the
graduation I was like I want to do Let
It Go from Frozen
I really did
um popular Disney song to sing at
karaoke I probably would do either
Hakuna Matata or you got a friend in me
um really Bach in Poco Loco I'm gonna go
for un poco loco I'm gonna go with
Hakuna Matata
I mean you know which face best
describes your mood confused
nervous
hopeful excited worried YOLO like the
face
the glasses I'm at YOLO I think I'm
gonna go YOLO YOLO
all right all right okay boink I'm gonna
I'm gonna go with hopeful tell us your
biggest weakness
so cute baby animal sweet social media
well depending on what we're talking
about reality TV a good book online
shopping it's gonna be greatness
actually we're like what's your biggest
weakness but it's actually like it's not
weak because we enjoy doing it yeah I'm
gonna go baby animals I love baby
animals dang it I actually do have some
weaknesses online shopping is a weakness
it really is a week I hate shopping
online it's always the wrong size uh
that's what I'm saying I always just
like let me go to the store I feel that
yeah our biggest weakness no a good book
yeah but baby animals are like a close
close second lately what puts you in the
best mood mama do
is Muay Thai on here all right so it's
between sunny days rainy days is out of
the question what are we talking about
here wind blowing through your hair oh
for sure I have no hair anymore though
um yeah I'm like what light breeze on a
warm day hmm
hmm waves hitting your feet fresh plants
oh fresh plants sunny days okay for me
three two one point
I'm Earth I got her you're definitely
Cloud I've been man I'm telling you
you're fired yeah yeah you said that so
I knew this just like Claude you're
patient and grounded impatient I think
you're patient you know what I think I
gotta give myself more credit I'm
patient and grounded you're known for
being really honest not only with
yourself but with others friends rely on
you to deliver the truth even it's
something they might not want to hear
that has earned you the trust of your
friends and your loved one you tend to
be a calm person
okay so it takes a lot to bring you out
of your character and while coloring
outside the lines can be fun from time
to time you gravitate toward more order
and stability your resilient caring and
always looking for ways to grow as a
person that's about right I think I'm on
my way that's true thanks that's true
yeah I'm Earth your personality matches
the fire element just like Ember you're
extremely passionate about the people
closest to you and the things you put
into your energy into your very emotion
driven which means when you love you
love hard but when you're upset it's
written all over your face yeah then
you've done this before too but you're
getting better at managing your emotions
so that's all that matters you're a
creative and bold person with a soul
that shine oh my God these are good
hey BuzzFeed thank you that's so
accurate that's pretty good it's like
horoscope it's like the best version of
me but I love that we're great we're
great
three two one thanks thanks bud fees
let me say that okay okay
thanks BuzzFeed we are the cast of
Pixar's Elemental and please go see our
movie in theaters please please oh all
right let's just look up okay I've got
the BuzzFeed this time I got it I got it
two one thanks bud please please calm
down okay can't say it and make sure to
go see Elemento in theaters
[Music]